come on there's eight billion mates here
and oh my god
[Applause]
look at these
[Music]
just sort of uh show everybody a
visualization of what we mean about
these two arcs so
winners will move on to what you see
above sort of indicated in blue is the
winner's bracket
and those people will actually have less
matches to worry about
on their way to grand final uh losers
from these
four first round matches however will
drop
into the what we're calling the
redemption arc uh
and they'll have to face uh many more
opponents
if they're going to make their way all
the way back not only win the redemption
bracket but then
face the winningest player
uh in the event to ultimately be crowned
tournament arc
champion the games are going to start
right now with kizzy k with the white
pieces
here we go his time all right let's
right there and uh we're going to go
and we're going to head back into d4
d466
e5 whoa okay it's kind of spicy
like takes e5 and we are in the live
just so let's go ahead bishop f4 being
played
f6 and f6 is
i i don't like to move f6 in the opening
because
we might have some ideas of bishop
captures on e5
and then queen h5 and it gets kind of
dicey
yeah and i hear all the time that uh
it's it's not really
a good idea to necessarily move the f
pawn early on
right right right so i almost want to
consider the f pawn of poison pawn in
the opening
um ooh this oh wow
we might see some fireworks here okay um
because he's developing his pieces but
um the knight going to h6 is a very bad
indication because
at least bishop captured a6 it ruins the
pawns and the f-pawn's very weak
and the reason we don't want to move the
f-pawn is because that is the weakest
pawn
right it's the only upon us that only
defended by the king
well it looks like his he did not
necessarily
either consider or go with the uh the
trade of the knight on h6 which would
double all these pawns make it
unappealing to castle in that direction
now he's thinking right what do you do
is he maybe thinking do i back up
or do i move back towards okay moves
back towards center
can i can i what what capture options do
i have
i like how she's looking at all her
pieces i see what you did there
i see what you did there but i mean if
you eat this
if you eat this then uh then i'll eat
the queen
oh man this is intense what do i do
let's try pinning actually
there's a pin she's like if nothing else
works the painting contour
hey i don't hate it you know what else i
i don't hate actually is that the chat
on twitch has voted they did a poll
before the game started to see what does
the chat think who's gonna win ollie or
kizzy and it's actually 48
percent for ali and 52 kizzy so the chat
also feels like this is a pretty close
match and i'm gonna have to agree with
them oh
what about g4 for white right now
hitting the knight and the bishop
this is this don't get tasty
i mean is there a way to escape that
tactic
in this position if you're black
i i don't i don't see a way it's
oh and he misses it yeah but you have to
see it you have to see it yeah
i mean you know it looks like a natural
developing move though right get your
night into the game
um and and i i appreciate that right
if if you're gonna miss something at
least miss it in a way that's principled
that's one thing what i want to do right
now is that i want to get my queen out
how do we do that how do we get our
queen out
okay okay there's a potential checkmate
but we have to get rid of this guy
that knight on d6 looks pretty tasty for
white
the uh the bishop is attacking oh there
we go
oh that takes immediately
but the bishop can and then
the other bishop can right so maybe i
don't know i would've took with the
bishop but
oh the king just moves okay yeah this is
tricky actually
this might be okay for one
but what other two can just take right
bishop bishop takes on d6 and bishop
takes one two six
oh there's a promotion oh boy a little
early kizzy
yeah a little early oh no
let's take a look and see how he feels
about his
land so far i never got this far
oh no
[Laughter]
i never got this far okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay
okay okay okay okay
oh my god bro
makes a lot of sense here backwards
bishop moves are also something that uh
that are difficult to see right we
always kind of think we want to move our
pieces forward we want to
attack we want to get over there into
their house but
these sort of retreating moves can be
obviously
you know can save you a game if you can
see them
we can see that this is probably one of
the first times a piece has moved past
their
right with knight to a4 so they've only
been playing on their half
for most of the game oh now it's still
available yeah let's see let's see
rook e1 and she found it wow
and let's listen in here can we listen
yeah
[Laughter]
wow ollie takes home
game one as black this is a match
dude this is amazing kizzy put up a
great fight
and i think i you know it could go
either way still in the second game but
like
what a confidence boost right
oh my god
oh my god i just wanna
i wanna know man what did i do to you
ollie i just wanna play fighting games
i just want to play fighting games ollie
okay okay okay
what do you think so far jt what's going
on on the board
flabbergasted i'm like there's a piece
going right and i was just talking about
because these openings
and here we are in full version of the
opening
he has an opening advantage and he plays
king to e7 delayed bonk cloud
whoa
wow we called it this is gonna get
exciting you know i don't know
what what it what what is going on here
this is literally a bonk and i think
honestly the position is not that bad if
we are able to play c6 king d7 king c7 i
think our king is perfectly placed
um kind of a re-wrap almost even maybe a
castle by hand get the rook out of there
first and then dig back in
but wow he said he wanted to play
fighting games like this is going to be
a fighting game
for sure
in fact chess may be one of the oldest
fighting games oh what
bro it is getting crazy here
i understand why her name is crazy
whoa neither player can castle now yes
absolutely whoa whoa whoa what is going
we on the queen
man we lost our waifu
uh we should definitely castle here i
think
i'm going to go defensive
patrol defense classical variation
he he has six points ahead of me that's
not good
now my my main objective is either to
get
queen 2 or
check the king
there's actually a potential tactic here
after d3
if ollie sees it could follow up maybe
with
bishop g5 but then onto f6 and it
actually
doesn't have as much teeth as i thought
it did
well i mean the same idea holds true if
if cause you decided to move that pawn
to f5 right
and then that that dd move would have
been really good because you're baiting
the tip
the take right so like let's say it
right in this position if they played
like f5
and you can bait them by playing d3 and
if they do take
then we have the line that you were
talking about
yeah and then ollie can bring the
material down
okay okay and actually it looks like she
has played d3
a little late for the tactics we
discussed but still not bad
right not bad at all
so i think that chat might have it right
here i think uh
factor is that indeed cloud opening
boats has
gambit accepted is the a fire opening
i agree probably the two
craziest tactics in chess
and we got him in one game this is gonna
be fantastic
and kissy uh may bring us uh
into a third game to determine the
winner of this pairing
but you got to play it right and we
we are also looking at the piece
development by aldi and
ollie is doing well the light square
bishop on e2 is not doing so hot
but if we can get our rooks maybe to f1
uh maybe double up the rooks on the f5
try to get some play
you know this is not over yet kenzie k
still has to find the right moves to
steal the deal and i know that ollie's
not just gonna
give up the game
and knight a6 might look strange but i
kind of feel like it's all right i mean
you can now bring it back into the game
with knight c5 and
get back into the center start pushing
putting pressure on the center pawns
i i really don't know what to do really
i don't know an important moment for
kizzy but look at the clock
serious time trouble this time six and a
half to two and a half
if i move this here then i'll be eaten
i don't have my queen i blundered i
blundered so bad when i lost my queen
ah now he's going to take either my rook
or my marquis
i hate him i hate him so much how about
we play it
how do we how are we going to play this
he's going to take either one of them
i want to check is there literally no
check
[Music]
please don't do it oh don't do it
oh don't do it
oh don't do it oh don't do it
we're saving our rook because our rook
is worth so many points
oh don't do it
oh my god okay um
he did it ollie he did it your marquee
is
toast oh yeah i hope it hopefully you
know some of the basic checkmates
because
that might come into play very very soon
wow
that's very bold of uh
okay just going in there's there was
some action that happened
so after the take 1956 bishop went back
g1 and then he was able to take the
knight
at the rook on a1 with his knight wow
for free but you know i wanted to ask
you about that
so do you feel like in in a sense you
can
find yourself or kizzy in that situation
find himself with almost too many
options and then just having to choose
one consumes
time on your clock yeah
um the thing that i say is if you find a
winning line
you're down on time just go for the
you don't have to find the best line if
you find a line that is winning and
you're like that's a
eight and five but you find them made it
and or if there's a made in three but
you
might you find oh you know you in two
pieces and you're still winning the game
but you just don't see the major three
sometimes it's just better to go for
that
that line found um
you know you can look after the game and
say oh man i missed something but it's
better to win
a winning game than to lose on time when
you're winning
okay cuz he's starting to make some
moves
i can't eat this anymore because the
queen is there
and that rook is awkward because now you
can't place it on c1 or d2
to try to help defend because the night
cover's so squares
what they might to do if i move here and
if you if he moves
just then it'll be a check and then
he'll eat my raw
i'd love to see kissy move a rook to the
c pile
uh-oh let's see if she doesn't play with
b2
and oh no oh no oh boy
okay now it's all about finding
checkmate within 30 seconds yes
can you do it because he has the chance
because he's starting to limit the
king's available squares
you can pawns here but this is a there
might be a stalemate threat here
the right piece don't make please still
wait that that would be really
unfortunate
oh gosh oh why'd i do that i forgot i
think this is i just had to do something
17 seconds left
just trying to work it out but not much
time
oh my god
almost anything is good here right
almost anything is good here but we got
to remember this time pressure
obviously winning the game and
uh i like the fact that uh
that kids he gave the king another
square the f6 square
this is um this is really nice under 20
seconds g5
hey we we do have a few checkmates
available in the position
and luckily for kizzy we white has this
d3 pawn that
is one more tempo yes just in case
okay here it is right
there's a few checkmates here and there
it is
wow kizzy has done it
kissy has tied the match yes
oh my god
oh my god now i can do this
now i can do this bro now i can do this
wow because he's got it he he
sing okay confidence
changed all right feeling bad about the
first game now feeling great
can do this
let's see the c4 and then knight c3
i'd have six of the really solid opening
are we gonna get uh
four knights and yeah we gotta four
nights
super solid opening uh bishop b5 yeah
this is
this is literally in the beginner
repertoire here this is
we went to roy lopez oh man
i told you these openings are good you
thought i was joking like these are
actually good openings
yeah they're both playing solidly here
in the first few moves and
uh wow we've this is what an exciting
first
match to launch tournament arc
objectively speaking
who's doing better here
listen down a piece or a piece of pawns
i like
hindi kay's position and
the computer person
[Laughter]
okay i mean what's at stake here uh that
black is maybe
missing about the position oh
um we literally just had to play one
move here and i think that move
is probably a knight here like e5
the idea is i will then attack
the knights take take
everything is pinned uh oh
i mean even then the pieces are just so
good and
i want to give you an idea here um that
a lot of people don't realize is that
black is actually down a piece
temporarily
and they're down the h8 rook it's not
playing
right the king is in a bad place the
king's on f8 and
if we can't activate that rook then
we're you know we're down
essentially we're down a rook right
exactly your player is on the bench
instead of on the field and it's gonna
take a bunch of moves
uh to get that rook active
kizzy of course has to find a way to
take advantage of that right
and right now it seems a little
[Music]
oh i might have spoken being a
commentator's curse again no i have to
stop commenting this girls yeah
it's coming through it's a thing in the
fighting community and like
whenever something bad is going to
happen the conversators are like wait
this is
the easy conversion it's like you drop a
combo it's called the american reset
and there you go kazee takes care of it
he sees the free piece
takes it and now now he's just got to
take this home right and and one of the
things that uh we say a lot of people
are
up material in a position
is to trade pieces off at that point
right
remove your opponent's ability to have
options oh i know this experience
[Music]
okay now i'm really mad i'm really mad
no i wanted to move this here no
no come on oh come on and then you're
going to eat one of my rugs
if i go here you'll eat this truck if i
go there you'll
no no
or ollie this match just has
slipped from her finger she had an
amazing amazing first game
and then struggled to maintain the
momentum
okay now the bishop has to block
if i'm not mistaken
and then you can potentially create some
separation afterwards maybe a queen
check on the back rank
to separate the king from defending that
bishop
and then more free stuff right
um that is true that is true we do need
to worry about
some stalemates oh
okay okay
i mean it's not it's never old until
it's over okay oh sure
sure and kissy still has plenty of
material here
you might be flustered by the fact that
that happened but you kind of have to
stop and look at the position and just
say you know what
everything's gonna be just fine
right and here a move like knight d4
uh just seems like crushing because
we're threatening a tactic with the uh
rook takes intakes and checkmate in the
back rank
and maybe we have the same plan here
okay
brook takes rook check it is a checkmate
so we have to be very very careful here
oh wait or yeah and now we have
a check with a capture here i feel like
kizzy's gotta have a sense here that
this one's in the bag and he's moving on
all right and let's actually listen and
see because this may be pretty
straightforward from here if you can see
it
yep
stalemate is a lot less likely now that
there aren't any pieces covering across
diagonals that would be
difficult to notice when moving right
uh there might there are still some
stalemate opportunities here
oh yeah
and we'll bring it back to the main
board here and what is
very likely to be the final seconds of
this game
but maybe some congestion here in these
moments i kind of like to get a piece
that doesn't need to be
in the game kind of away from the action
to prevent stalemates
is kissy gonna get greedy here and pick
up another queen
oh there's two queens let's see let's
see what's gonna happen here
i mean why not i mean if you don't mate
this is tense what any problem
permission to a bishop
is this is this the same you know as a
taunt in a fighting game right now like
i think i think that's a taunt i think
that's a danton from street fighter 4.
playing some
okay this is it right here there has to
be a mate here come on there's eight
billion maids here
and oh my gosh around this person
and oh no no no
he's all hive he doesn't know because he
doesn't know i don't think right
wait what i dropped
[Laughter]
and kisses
oh my god
oh my god thank you
thank you jesus
look at these blunders there
okay so it's a draw wait what a draw i
don't know if i'm
happy or not i'm not happy about it at
all
and kizzy is i called it
i didn't know the stalemate rule oh no
wow
we have tie breaks
in the first match
of tournament arc what on earth
wow i think this is the flat armor chat
is right this is way too dank
oh my gosh gt can you believe this we're
gonna have a 3-0
tie break match winner takes all sudden
death
i need to hear what ollie is thinking i
just need to know
all right how she feels after two losses
you know what let's just do one
more a loss and a draw but it felt like
a loss
that's our safest bet right now okay
she's playing safe
right quick opening developing moves yep
not a lot of time so moving quickly is
i good it's dutch this is uh let's play
it safer now
you're pinning my king awesome
okay the king is not going to go here
ollie likes that move b4
continuing to make you move that picture
for a scoop
let's defend
yeah let's just do a normal italian
opening i think that's the best way
[Music]
we're practically doing the same thing
up that's some free stuff
but wait a minute
are there tactics gt
what is happening here where are the
opportunities
what opportunities huh
oh there um there might be an
opportunity uh
very very soon i think uh oh okay oh no
is it a commentator's curse
if it becomes equal yeah
yes yes you literally like you're not
supposed to even compensate so basically
finding a community
you're not supposed to say what's about
to happen because it's not going to
happen
absolutely oh he's just going to finish
his combo
matter of fact he's drawn a combo uh and
he lost the game it just
usually happened
oh my
now the king doesn't have a castle to go
back to awesome
is she just in shock she didn't even
comment on losing her queen
we have a double pawn too this isn't
looking good
but let's not forget she can still flag
him he's like down almost a full minute
almost a full minute no increment
to be honest this isn't really
protecting the king that much she's just
gotta calm down
this piano is protecting maybe look at
the clock
what can we expect now i don't know
can we see what he's thinking about
because he's literally
down almost a minute now
he just said stressful dude
spending a lot of time thinking about
moves
oh my gosh
ollie would double his time now more
than more than a minute
you have to play fast here you're
winning but
got to move okay he gives up a bishop
here
but if you activate your other pieces
and move quickly coming up on less than
30 seconds here for kizzy k
ollie with a little over a minute
oh my gosh gt this is gonna come down to
the wire man
oh man yeah i don't i don't know i don't
i don't know whose game this is this is
this is crazy
oh man this is okay getting crazier by
the second oh my gosh
what's happening here wild
i am literally not even going to talk
about the chess right here i'm just
going to say that i hope they have a
good game
i'm not getting blamed no i'm not
getting blamed okay guys
oh my gosh 15 seconds my
you got to move you got to make moves 11
10 less oh my gosh kizzy is
you got a flag here he probably thinks
that he has he probably thinks that he
has increment he doesn't
oh no three seconds go go no move move
move oh no
this is it he only gets like three
and that's it
it's over wait is this is this is this
does this count as a win is this a win
is this oh is this okay what does this
mean
i don't know
[Music]
what does this mean what does that mean
what does it mean it's time
bro oh man kizzy knows that it's over
but
ollie baby is just in shock that she's
done it she's come away with a win in
the first match
what an unbelievable match and uh
kizzy i'd actually like to start with
you what was that like
coming back in game two and then
having that draw take you into uh
into a tiebreaker to to finish the match
out
so honestly i was like the first
game definitely was like oh man i
like i just got played right and then so
the second game i was just like all
right
uh you know they do a different type of
like unique
opening and i i capitalize on the queen
really early so i felt like
i had like a lot of like you know board
control
after that and then after that you know
you know i was able to secure that and
then the third game uh i realized i was
looking at the timer and i was like oh i
gotta do something right
but as i was like thinking of doing
something i was thinking of like three
other things
and it looked like everything passed
over that like yeah i have to like do
something
otherwise it's gonna become a draw but
also
i was so like in the mind of just trying
to like
basically get a guaranteed win when i
should have just
won with the things i had what i mean by
guaranteeing me i was like
oh let me get all of these things and
just like you know
overrun right but i forgot that that's
not how that works
so after all i was like dang
you know like all right so now all right
we could probably play another game
right and then
it said three minutes and i was like oh
it's all like
i'm going to lose right now i got three
minutes i'm already bad with tommy so
now you're going to give me less time
but oh good games
i was like oh good game she won you
played amazing chats um
especially that last game you were
playing so fast
what was going through your head in that
last game because you know
going from winning to losing the second
game
and then drawing the third game when you
thought i think you
were like oh no no i'm losing i'm losing
and then winning the last one how did
you feel
i sincerely
did not know what i was doing to be very
blunt
to be very sincere i i was because kizzy
i did so many blenders and kizzy kept on
eating all my pieces i
i i just so the thing that came to my
mind is like okay i just gotta move
fast i gotta move like sonic gotta go
you know that's all actually
well i got i got okay so
but that was really cool though you keep
you kept on eating my pieces he kept on
trapping me i did so many blenders
man it was so cool it was a good game
yeah
it was it was a good game
[Music]
[Applause]
you